the Cincinnati zoos most famous resident
is back in the limelight this morning
Fiona the hippo became an international
phenomenon last year after she was born
six weeks premature zookeepers nursed
her back to health and Fiona became the
smallest hippo ever to survive
now her remarkable story has inspired a
new children's book called what else
Fiona the hippo we recently visited the
zoo to catch up with that beloved animal
I would absolutely say that Fiona is a
celebrity people come from all over the
world to see her it seems as though
everyone loves Fiona I just think that
the little layers in her face yes Fiona
was born on January 24th of 2017 at that
point we had no idea she would survive
no one in the world has ever hand reared
a premature hippo that we know of so it
was a once-in-a-lifetime opportunity
thankfully now she's about a year and a
half old and she is thriving I got to
meet and talk with the trainer and the
various people at the zoo some of the
words that they used to describe her
were diva and character and sassy she
really is all of the above now with
something as cute and vibrant as Fiona
and her story being so popular hopefully
it kind of you know draws attention to
hippos where maybe people didn't think
they were so cute before now that
they've paid attention to Fiona they
definitely you know see how amazing
hippos really are the SAG is very true
like
the hippo horrible the book Fiona the
hippo is on sale now proceeds will
benefit the Cincinnati Zoo so get it
yeah Yona the hip I don't know the hippo
think it was Rex a seer Fiona and I
think whatever it takes is bad the
booked on my mind right